yeah welcome to this video playing soft
rain from Costa Rica okay not one of
those flags lat you Jesse all day okay
went for the Bogle and dumb yeah the
bogo are Wed t6 Bishop f4 a queen a 40
know he i can i can click Bishop d7 of
everything else fails okay yeah it's a
sort of strange Catalan bogo mix where
we are managed to play cookie five hmm
ok so I didn't have any problems to play
five now that's interesting i can i can
play that and i will i will preserve the
bishop the bishop is a nicely placed on
c5 sometimes you can even play fruit
looking at texts like Knight g4 and so
on on f2 okay should I go pee should be
seven so that all night therefore i can
i can take it and i don't know night a
for Bishop e7 you might take let's let's
do that so should i play age five yeah
let's do that i have not cancelled and
maybe i can make use of that I think he
needs to react hmm Quincy eight teen age
too
and maybe maybe to do this first get
this piece near the king I was thinking
about Quincy eight of course Quincy
eight yeah why not Quincy eight
attacking h 3 i'd have ideas like age 49
h 7 he might take on f6 but i'm not sure
that this is such a big deal it would
open up the GFL yeah i'm now night age 7
or not
YH from the question is h 4g for cannot
actually sacrifice mm nice maybe
night h70 we'll go back to the two nite
g4 instantly is probably just just
terrible ok let's play it from
the question is on gphone maybe maybe
Bishop g4 Bishop g4 takes Queen tags if
it goes Bishop f6 I might have h 3 which
looks so weird okay if I take with the
night King and age 38 a bishop f3 okay
let's do that first my ideas after if he
captures I have six which oops yeah
looks forced I thought about h three
intermediate myth and his his knitter he
needs to player 2 h 1 now I think divot
take no as got 93 mmm we are taking the
bishop s actually losing a bit of time
is always got 93 I didn't really think
about that okay
let's hope it's um it's enough probably
not objectively night f4 there are some
ideas the bishop on c5 is a strong piece
and his bishop on h1 is not doing much
yeah this piece sacrifice is not is
probably not working objectively I don't
need much time just lie there for long
castles so it's dangerous quickly okay I
want you to go there anyway yeah but I
don't think you can really take on their
forum this looks some really dangerous
if it takes and opens up the G file for
me
yeah this I cannot take on iphone I'm
not sure maybe rook g8 Queen g4 it's
starting to get them a bit a bit tricky
well now maybe it is enough compensation
even what exactly is a smooth if you
move something like night f5 there's
always also Queen g2 to consider the
Queen sec okay it took it I didn't think
this was possible because I worked g8
and this is really threatening Queen g2
hmm
yeah let's play this first okay Queen
therefore Queen g2 is made yeah this is
also made check I wasn't sure about
neither for neither for I thought maybe
Bishop d45 this is made next move white
resins fairly a fairly typical mating
checkmate with the both with both rooks
here the point or the the move to to
look at is this one I didn't see made
after that there's one Bishop f2 is the
mid yeah I'm naughty not difficult now
Queen g3 mate ok I probably would have
found that I thought that this might be
a good move we had also wins with me it
also went Queen Bishop to g5 Versailles
the key here ok this is actually also
made just takes a bit longer yeah I
don't know my P sec probably not not
correct but but interesting ah Knight
takes is actually very good for black I
did I considered it but not really in
depth and it's not difficult to see
actually if he goes here I just I just
march the pawn check yeah check this is
fairly fairly easy yeah look at this
check and then there's queen Ashley
coming this is what I didn't see I
didn't calculate so so far as well would
have been good after this it's probably
not not really sufficient it's tricky i
mean in a blitz game
this is a play will sacrifice but
probably not something for for
correspondence chess or something but
this is this is some probably losing
night f5 film was was a bit tougher but
it also looks really dangerous after
that I've got this instant threat yam
very tricky for white to defend okay
thanks for watching